This lecture is about the sentiment
classification.
If we assume that most of the elements
in the opinion representation are already
known, then our only task maybe just
the sentiment classification as shown
in this case.
So suppose we know who is the opinion
holder and what's the opinion target and also
know the content and context of the
opinion.
Then we mainly need to decide the opinion
sentiment of the review.
So this is a case of just using
sentiment classification for
understanding opinion.
Sentiment classification can be
defined more specifically as
follows:
The input is opinionated text
object.
The output is typically, a sentiment
label or sentiment tag, and that can
be designed in two ways.
One is polarity analysis where we have
categories such as positive, negative
or neutral.
The other is emotion analysis.
That can go beyond polarity to
characterize the feeling of the opinion
holder.
In the case of polarity analysis, we
sometimes also have numerical ratings,
as you often see in some reviews on the
web.
Five might denote the most positive and
one maybe at most negative,
for example. In general you have just
discrete categories to characterize
the sentiment.
In emotion analysis, of course, there
are also different ways to design the
categories.
The six most frequently used
categories are happy, sad, fearful,
angry, surpised and disgusted.
So as you can see, the task is
essentially a classification task or
categorisation task.
As we've seen before, so it's a special
case of text categorization.
This also means any text categorization
method can be used to do sentiment
classification.
Now, of course, if you just do that,
the accuracy may not be good because
sentiment classification does require
some improvement over regular text
categorization technique or simple text
categorization technique.
In particular, it needs two kinds of
improvements.
One is to use more sophisticated
features that may be more appropriate
for sentiment tagging, as I will
discuss more in a moment.
The other is to consider the order of
these categories.
An especially polarity analysis, very
clear that order here and so these
categories are not all that
independent.
There is order among them, and so it's
useful to consider the order.
For example, we could use ordinal
regression to do, and that's something
that will talk more about later.
So now let's talk about some features
that often very useful for text
categorization and text mining in
general, but some of them are
especially also needed for sentiment
analysis.
So let's start from the simplest one,
which is character n-grams.
You can just have a sequence of
characters as a unit,
and they can be mixed with different
n(s),  different lengths.
And this is a very general way, and a very
robust way to represent the text data.
You could do that for any language pretty
much.
And this is also robust to spelling
errors or recognition errors, right?
So if you misspelled the word by 1
character and this representation
actually would allow you to match this
word when it occurs in the text
correctly.
So misspelled word and the correct form
can be matched because they contain
some common n-grams of characters.
But of course such a representation
would not be as discriminative as
words.
So next we have word n-grams, a
sequence of words and again we can mix
them with different lengths.
Uni Grams are actually often very
effective for a lot of text processing
tasks and that's mostly because words are well
designed
features by humans for
communication, and so they often good
enough for many tasks, but it's not
good or not sufficient for sentiment
analysis
clearly.
For example, we might see a sentence
like it's not good or it's not as good
as something else.
So in such a case, if you just take a
good and that would suggest positive,
it's not good,
so it's not accurate, but if you
take the bigram, not good together, and
then it's more accurate, so longer
n-grams are generally more
discriminative and they are more
specific.
If you match it and it says a lot and
it's accurate.
It's unlikely, very ambiguous.
But it may cause overfitting because
with such very unique features the
machine learning program can easily
pick up such features from the training
set and to rely on such unique features
to distinguish categories.
An obviously that kind of classifier
won't generalize well to future data when
such discriminating features will not
necessarily occur.
So that's a problem of overfitting.
That's not desirable.
We can also consider part of speech
tag
n-grams, if we can do part of speech
tagging and for example, adjective,
noun could form a pair.
We can also mix N grams of words and N
grams of part of speech tags.
For example, the word great might be
followed by a noun and this could become
a feature, a hybrid feature.
That could be useful for sentiment
analysis.
So next we can also have word classes,
so these classes can be syntactic
like a part of speech tags.
Or could be semantic and they might
represent concepts in the thesaurus or
ontology like word net.
Or they can be recognized the named
entities like people or place and these
categories can be used to enrich the
representation as additional features.
We can also learn word clusters
empirically, for example we talked
about mining associations of words and
so we can have cluster of
paradigmatically related words or
sementically related words.
And these clusters can be features to
supplement the word based
representation.
Furthermore, we can also have frequent
pattern syntax and these could be
frequent word set.
The words that formed a pattern do
not necessarily occur together or next
to each other.
But we also have locations where the
words might occur more closely
together.
And such patterns provide a more
discriminative features than words,
obviously, and they may also generalize
better than just the regular n-grams
because they are frequent, so you can
expect them to occur also in test data
so they have a lot of advantages, but
they might still face the problem of
overfitting as the features become more
complex.
This is the problem in general, and the
same is true for parse tree based
features where you can use a parse tree
to derive features such as frequent
subtrees or paths, and those are even
more discriminating, but they also are
more likely to cause overfitting.
And in General, Patton discovery
algorithms are very useful for feature
construction, because they allow us to
search in a larger space of possible
features that are more complex than
words that are sometimes useful.
So in general, natural language
processing is very important to derive
complex features.
They can enrich text representation.
So for example, this is a simple
sentence that I showed you long time
ago, and in another lecture.
So from these words we can only derive
simple world n-grams representations or
character n-grams.
But with NLP we can enrich the
representation with a lot of other
information such as part of speech
tags, parse trees or entities, or even
speech act.
Now with such enriched information, of
course, then we can generate a lot of
other features, more complex features,
like a mixed grams of word and part of
speech tags.
Or even a part of parse tree.
So in general, feature design actually
affects categorization accuracy
significantly, and it's a very
important part of any machine learning
application. In general,
I think it would be most effective if
you can combine machine learning, error
analysis and domain knowledge in designing
features.
So first you want to use domain
knowledge and your understanding of the
problem to design seed features.
And you can also define a basic feature
space with a lot of possible features
for the Machine learning program to
work on.
And machine learning can be applied to
select the most effective features or
construct the new features that feature
learning.
And these features can then be further
analyzed by humans through error
analysis.
And you can look at the categorization
errors and then further analyze what
features can help you recover from
those errors or what features cause
overfitting and cause those errors, and
so this can lead to feature validation
that would revise the feature set and
then you can iterate and we might
consider using a different feature
space.
So NLP enriches text representation.
As I just said and because it enriches
the feature space.
It allows much larger search space of
features.
And there are also many meaningful
features that can be very useful for a
lot of tasks.
But be careful not to use a lot of
complicated features because it can
cause overfitting or otherwise you have
to do the training carefully, not to
let
overfitting happen.
So a main challenge in designing features,
a common challenge is to optimize the
tradeoff between exhaustivity and
specificity.
And this trade off, it turns out to be
very difficult.
Now, exhaustivity means we want the
features to actually have high coverage
of a lot of documents.
And so in that sense, you wanted
features to be frequent.
Specificity requires the feature to be
discriminative, so naturally infrequent
features tend to be more
discriminating, so this really caused
tradeoff between frequent versus
infrequent features, and that's why
feature design is generally an art.
That's perhaps the most important part
in applying machine learning to any
problem in particular.
In our case, for text categorization,
or more specifically, sentiment
classification.